now back for the fifth week is our
ex-frontier lawmen and nephew of wyatt
earp from sacramento california whose
category is the wild west
virgil art
all your friends are out there you feel
all
right forward
new suit that's very pretty
isn't it
bird you come from a family of law
enforcement officers you're the nephew
of the most famous of the united states
marshals you were marshall yourself
so you should know was it was it tougher
or easier to enforce law in your days
much tougher
well because there was some there was
more crime no there was lesser crime the
peoples were more honest
you could leave a poker gold you know
home and leave the door wide open it was
as safe as in the bank brother why was
the job tougher well because
you were the arresting officer
you took every responsibility on
yourself you're arresting often
detecting squad car jailer and the whole
thing wrapped up in one all
one job
uh if it's not too personal i don't
think this will hurt you now how much
did you get paid in those days for all
those duties 75 dollars a month and very
happy all of it 75 a month how much did
uh
how much did wyatt make he was well the
most why i made it as a marshall was
when he was over all the rest of martin
dodson he got 250 a month 250 a month
for being a marshall that was a pretty
rugged job well couldn't you have made
more money in other ventures
with some more fortunes
but
the orcs are low man you can't make
anything else out of them
and
it wouldn't be otherwise a bitcoin well
i'm very thankful the earps and other
men of your
breed were the law man because the word
for fellows like you were liable to have
a horseman riding up right now and hold
up the whole studio
well virgil i'm as i say it's a
fascinating history you've had and i'm
very
thrilled to know you and learn more
about it from week to week well now
let's get down to the game itself last
week roger you won sixteen thousand
dollars you've had a week to think it
over and you're here tonight to tell us
whether you're gonna take the 16
thousand or
gamble it and go for thirty two where we
do or nothing you're going for thirty
two thousand
dollars all right let's get going how
would you escort virgil into the booth
[Music]
virgil please you hear me all right
yeah
you're all comfortable ready for the
question for the question okay they have
it please ben
the categories you know is the wild west
the question is worth 32
for that amount virgil i want you to
answer the following questions about the
colorful west first
here is a map from rand mcnally's
history of our united states would you
hand that map in
for mr please ben there's the map
now that map that you have before you
virgil shows one of the most famous
trails
of the west
what is its name
and what was its purpose
and in what town did it first end and
why
then
wait a second virgil we'll come back to
that i want to give you the rest of this
question now
second part of the question buffalo bill
cody was one of the most famous of the
scouts and indian fighters before he
became a showman
against what two indian tribes did he
scout for the army from 1868 to 1872
at the battle of indian creek he killed
an indian chief in hand-to-hand combat
what was the chief's name
and what award
did cody receive from the united states
government for his services
next part of the question virgil one of
the most notorious outlaws of the west
was jesse james
a song became popular immediately after
his death that went like this listen to
this song
for his life three children
they were brave
but that dirty little town that shot
down mr tower has laid poor jazz in the
grave
did you hear that
all right virgil i want to ask you a
couple of questions about that song now
who was the mr howard mentioned in the
song
and who was the man referred to as the
dirty little coward
and what was his connection with jesse
james
now for the final part of this question
listen very carefully
in order to identify their cattle
the western ranchers created thousands
of personal distinctive brands
now look at the brands we have
illustrated may i have those please then
we should pass those
into virgil
forget the map for a moment now look at
those brands virgil
first examine brand number one up in
that left hand corner
why was this particular brand chosen for
the ranch that used it
now examine brand number two
their number two is the first brand used
in america
by whom
brand number two is on the bottom there
now examine brand number three which has
a very interesting story behind it
what caused this brand to be chosen
that's the question virgil you have a
little time to take over your answer
good luck well where do we stop here
right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]
right virgin we'll start with the
question concerning the map
now what is the name of the famous trail
that's chisholm trail that is correct
what purpose did it serve it served to
run the longhorns to the shipping market
on the railroad from the long orange
from where
or from the panhandle of texas that is
correct in what town did it originally
end
why it ended in abilene on the accident
fragrant
that is correct
why did it end there
well the railroad hadn't moved up yet
that was the first
that was really the end of the railroad
when they shipped from abilene that is
correct
now
you can put both those things down now
virgil we'll get to the brands a little
later so hold them hold them with you
now the second part of the question
concerned buffalo bill cody buffalo bill
cody served as scout for the army
against two indian tribes which two
tribes
the soos and the shanghams that is
correct
what indian sheath did he defeat in
combat
uh yellow
what was that
that is correct
what high decoration did he receive he
received the congressional medal of
honor
that is correct
now concerning the song that you heard
who in the song was mr howard
for jesse james
that is correct
who was referred to as the dirty little
coward
bob ford bob ford is correct and what
was his connection with jesse james well
he was one of the gang of outlaws under
jesse and frank james
that is correct he was a member of his
gang now you can get a picture of the
brands in front of you concerning the
brands virgil brand number one
why was it chosen by the ranch that used
it
well as a ranch in texas with covers
approximately six counties or ten
counties the x was a numeral number for
the ten
and the i
was for uh
virtual to be fair
in texas
tandem texas illinois
that is in
texas okay that is right now brand two
this is the first brand used in america
yeah by whom was it used for cortez
fernando cortez is correct to capture
mexico one more brand to identify for
thirty two thousand dollars what unusual
reason
caused the choice of this brand
well they were having a big poker game
and the rancher that owned this
particular ranch had went broke as far
as money
so he staked his ranch against the money
on one bed
and his opposer
had four sixes and went in the ranch
yep so he thought nothing better for
branding iron
than four sixes the man who won the
ranch wanted the poker hand with four
sixes four sixes and that became its
brand
yes
you're right for 32 000.
[Applause]
and marshall congratulations again
you've just won 32 big ones your next
question is worth 64 000 and if you can
dig up and i mean literally dig up a
better expert than you are you can bring
him to the studio and help you if you
decide to go for 64 000. i seen
an
ex-arizonan ex-senator
yesterday in the office yeah
wonderful well i'm sure he was glad to
see you virgil thanks for being with us
tonight we'll see you next week good
night
[Music]